It is kissing? I don't know.
It's when you have a special feeling inside.
You just be happy, and well, it's happy like Cupid comes out.
It feels like a happy day.
Love is when you feel like you feel good for someone.
You love them more like anyone else.
You just think that they're the greatest people on the Earth.
You like somebody and you hug them.
When I love someone, I give them a present.
I would go up to her and I'd say, "I love you. Will you marry me?"
Just give it straight out, right to her.
And then give her the ring, obviously.
He does this and then they kiss.
He kisses the girl.
Maybe, like a nice mansion at a sunset near...
I think it's actually nice to kind of give a little speech,...
...like some kind of speech showing that he really does love her a lot.
"Can you please, please marry me?"
She might say yes.
"Yes, I'll marry you."
A diamond ring will be, I guess,...
...it'll be fine for her, but it has to be really shiny.
I guess.
It sparkles.
I think this is what usually happens.
The boy buys a really, really, really nice ring for the engagement ring.
He just wants her to say yes, you know.
You put them on and it looks so pretty.
They wanna have more family and they wanna have a baby.
I don't know how you get a baby even.
Maybe it comes just by itself.
Maybe it's from magic.
And it's love.
And that's it!